[Music]
you wanna pocket you wanna podcast I got
a smart cat you want a cat I got a spot
cat
you wanna you wanna you wanna you wanna
do you wanna bug heads do you want to
show you you get you guys from
do with this bro buddy mo it's about
time to move your shed everybody's
promised place for that legend Kevin
Smith
[Music]
and there have been sharks that have
been sighted that have been that size
and they've actually caught some that
were 21 feet so it was a credible animal
we were making of doing the initial
studies of the great white shark I went
to the Steinhardt and I borrowed this
set of Jaws which was huge
18:24 we met made our shark larger by
another 5 or 6 feet but we we kept
everything in proportion the teeth when
I started doing the actual drawings you
know for the construction of the shark
we used everything in proper proportion
welcome to SModcast I'm Kevin Smith okay
one of the most unheralded unsung jobs
in film production is the production
designer man without the production
designer you have no set you have no
look of the film you have nothing to see
other than an idea of a director and a
screenwriter production designer is
responsible for everything you see when
you watch a movie the director just
traffic's what the production designer
gives them my whole career I've worked
with a few different production
designers when I worked with for many
years
Robert Holtzman nickname was rat face
and he loved his nickname he put it into
the credits of every movie we did with
the exception of Jersey girl because the
people who produced the movie said this
movie's gonna be an awards movie we
can't have a name like rat face up in
the credits so for the first time ever
in his career
Robert Holtzman put his name solely as
Robert Holtzman left rat face out of it
rat face his job as a production
designer it was to take that script of
mine turn it into something that we can
shoot on sets that we could shoot on
bring the world to life before we can
roll a single frame of film and on that
movie I worked with the great Vilmos
Sigmund and and Vilmos like Lazlo Koufax
the two of them have escaped from
Hungary during the Hungarian Revolution
with cameras under their arms and
footage of the revolution and both
ironically wound up winning
cinematography Oscars Vilmos and rat
face on Jersey girl worked very closely
so much so that while we were making the
movie periodically this was in
Philadelphia
you would hear Vilno Sigmund yellow rat
face gets me rats face I need the red
face then everyone would go scrambling
because bill mosh was fairly old at this
point whatnot and he didn't want to make
an old genius wait so we'd go find a rat
face everyone would freeze and like
gotta get brown face von rönn face you'd
find rat face
bring him to Belle mo shan set and
rat-faced would say yeah ville motion
what do you need looking for you know
obviously a production designer question
to respond to but instead ville motion
rats vase get to me coffee you know how
I like it so the production designer
doesn't always get even on the set the
respect that they deserve man but today
we're talking to a production designer
who has all the respect in the world the
first production designer whose name I
ever learned when I was a child because
this person imagined for me an image of
that that I take with me everywhere in
life even when I see a real shark in
footage from any number of documentaries
National Geographic specials I always go
I'm snot shark because this man
introduced me to a shark when I was a
kid and in the most influential movie
perhaps I've ever seen in my life at age
five my parents take me to a drive-in
movie theater to go see jaws it was the
movie of the summer the movie event of
that entire year as we all know
historically it changed the movie
business movies went from being platform
release city-by-city to being released
all at once nationwide thanks to jaws
opening on I think on three hundred
screens back in 1975 so the movie
undeniably had such an impact on pop
culture such an impact on filmmaking
such an impact on the world in general I
speak to you as somebody who grew up in
a short áown in New Jersey and
Highland's with a beach sandy hook and I
stopped going to the beach at age five
because I saw what happens in the water
thanks to jaws and whatnot now when we
say jaws of course the layman if you're
lucky
think of Oh Steven Spielberg sometimes
literary folks go
Oh Peter Benchley these are the rock
star names of the movies beside
obviously a Roy Scheider and Robert Shaw
and Richard Dreyfuss but for me a rock
star name of Jaws throughout my entire
childhood and a guy who's been
incredibly closely associated not just
with the jaws itself but the entire jaws
franchise which I celebrate I'm a big
jaws fan from top to bottom and stuff is
a man who we get to speak to today on
Sundance on SModcast
my my house is not ready for the honor
of this man being just on the audio
coming through the internets of my house
man obviously with quarantine and
whatnot we're out not in the same room
and what but he's here in California I'm
here in California and through the
miracle of the Internet's we're going to
talk to the first production designer
whose name I ever learned in my entire
life and perhaps for me the most
important production designer in the
world give it up for Joe Alves everybody
how are you sir I'm great I'm great
you started in this business we're get
to jaws of course man you've got this
amazing book that's coming out where
it's available right now called
designing jaws yeah beautiful book
fantastic and for you I would imagine
this is a movie you can't get away from
your whole life you've been talking
about jaws how nice to celebrate it in
your own hardcover they've been many
Jaws books over the years nice of you to
have yours I would imagine at this point
because your journey with this movie is
singularly different from everybody
else's we all got to enjoy it Spielberg
got to fret making it whatnot but you're
the person without whom we don't get to
see Amity Island we don't even get to
see the shark the interesting thing
about the book Dennis Prinz wrote is
that it's there's not too many books
that deal with production design
you know they deal with the director of
the actors and so this goes in the
inside not necessarily about me but bob
maddie and the various people that built
the shark and so you know it's not the
making of the movie as much as a
preparing you know to make the movie
which is something that nobody really
ever gets talking about when they talk
about Jaws and they'd be talking about
it for
45 years now there's a 45th anniversary
limited edition blu-ray that Universal
is putting out which has cutscenes that
I never saw before behind the scenes
footage that was shot while the movie
was being made
Universal always puts together a very
lovely jaws package for the for the jaws
fans but in all those documentaries it's
always what happened once everyone gets
to Martha's Vineyard yeah how things
feel wrong and when this book is more
about before one even gets tomorrow you
know before it was before it was even a
movie before they had a deal with
Universal I was involved I mean there
was no charge number or anything you
know it was just I was presented to
galley sheets to make some drawings but
can I met you something about Vilmos
Eggman yeah for because I love the guy
you've worked with him as well the
Sugarland Express and Close Encounters
that's right oh my voice Close
Encounters over and he was offered Jost
and he turned it down Steven went to him
yeah he died didn't want to make a shark
movie you know isn't that amazing that
is not it's not that bill bill Butler
didn't do a great job but Vilmos was
just an amazing guy and he had just been
on Sugarland Express with both you and
Steven Spielberg frankly so it would
have made sense to keep the team
together yeah exactly you keep the team
together and what's ironic about it too
is if anybody that knows anything about
Vilmos is i don't know if it was the
case back then in the 70s but when I
worked with them 30 years later he he
was a lap swimmer every day he would go
swimming he like he did a hundred laps
we had to put him in a hotel with at
Olympic sized pool so maybe he was like
I don't want to I don't want to deal
with the water in that way it was it was
just you know it was disappointing that
he turned it down no doubt because we
developed we started off not that great
of a relationship because I was a
television guy you know and it wasn't
until midway through
Sugarland that he needed something to
cover this whole big parking lot for
where the outdoor theater was
and I said that's okay I'll get you a
huge silk I'll do it then he said oh
well you could do that
okay so then we became you know and of
course at Close Encounters we were
really close together you know because
we had 48 photo photo floods you know
parks and so anyway was that something
else we'll get back to Jos let's let's
dive into the beginning your career man
did I free correctly did you really work
on Forbidden Planet is that how far back
you go yeah I animated the end really
yeah
okay briefly I what I came down I was I
was born in Bay Area went to San Jose
State for a year and then I really
wanted to do movies so I came down and I
went to a art school called sure nards
which is now Cal arts and I was there
for a semester a year and then I was
looking for a summer job I want to stay
in LA and this friend of Mines he said
oh my my wife's father works at Disney's
maybe you can get a child I said well I
don't think I was just turned 19 you
know and so I called her father and he
happened to be the guy that hired the
people at Disney so he said bring your
portfolio so I I don't think I'm alright
so I brought it in
he said you're too late for the training
program but I could put into special
effects right now okay so I go in and
there's this room and Marilyn Marion I
said what I do she said you flip the
page it's a draw between I said oh
that's cool well after a series of she
was working for this guy Carlyle was
working for Josh mentor who was the King
animator did the fam fire and Bambi
night vote anyway long story short she
had to leave Dwight was working for Josh
theatrical house well in two months I'm
assisting Josh matter I mean normally it
takes years to become a sister and he's
given me this we're on did white papers
you know because it's CinemaScope kind
of thing and I and I'm drawing the edge
and then Erin passive
two trainees and stuff and so that's
beginning and that I was 19 and then
yeah the it'd what what happened in rich
I still have some original joins do you
really yeah I actually Greg Nicotero I
was a collector you know Greg of course
it's Greg a years ago Greg gave me I
which he got from you
a copy of the blueprints yeah for the
shark and he gave me a copy and I fried
and framed in my house I know well he
had a couple ID's you know and he gave
me one and I just gave him back one but
no we talked we talked last week in fact
he co-wrote the book he wrote the
introduction to this book hmm and so
we've been out book signing we don't do
anything anymore right the anyway that's
how it started so when you so from that
point like once you're working on
Forbidden Planet you're is that like
alright I'm officially in the movie
business like what was the next job well
the thing is I was a I became an
assistant evader and one quick story
about just me before I leave I really
want to get it to live-action as I'm
drawing a little cookie for one of the
fairies and a Sleeping Beauty you have
art in Sleeping Beauty yeah that was all
animated really yeah the first one yeah
it was animated Sleeping Beauty holy and
you worked on yeah and I'm drawing a
cookie we do cuz we're doing the effect
and this guy who reaches over he says no
the cookie should look like this it was
Walt Disney I I mean it was like oh okay
well we all call it luck so that was a
and what am I gonna say oh my good lord
if only that Walt Disney knew one day
you would create a most fearsome
cinematic creature that ever existed
what yeah anyway so then I really want
us to get into live-action after a
couple years animating but you know then
you know Terra because I was looking at
your career your bio and what was so
different is it was all studio system
you know 31
these six until the seventies so you
came in five or six different you know
MGM parama whatever and I came in as a
junior set designer and you go work in
the draft room and then you're lucky
become a senior then if you make your
graduate to an art director and it was
pretty much that way on every department
you could only kind of work up through
the system nobody could enter in the top
wasn't until the mid-70s with Spielberg
Lucas guys like that sort of separated a
little bit just a totally different
thing you know so wait so you when you
make the transition a live-action what
are you working on at that point what's
the first like studio live-action movie
you became you go to the Union and they
give you is there okay there it's
available now you could go get a job in
this lab Kenosha hired me at a studio
called zip it was a television services
outer space it will we went to good and
I drew that and then my next job was MGM
working on mutiny on the bounty drawing
a boat and then I was at Warner Brothers
doing some things for my fair lady I
mean you know you and then my big thing
came I became a senior and I'm working
at Universal and I do it mad mad world
oh really
that pretty steadily you know for six
months and they kept me on that I built
models and you know Stanley Kramer you
know so it was and that's how you just
sort of developed until they made me
assistant art director as an assistant I
was very lucky in frankera though and we
worked on change of habit which is
previs president's last movie mm-hmm and
then the big one as an assistant was
torn curtain Alfred Hitchcock what was
it like to work with hitch
everybody you know ties really yeah I
mean if you have an art director sister
art director if you weren't on the
shooting it was ties and sport coats and
he always wore a black suit with a black
tie and he would come in in the morning
we go to have coffee with coffees and
doughnuts and he was sit there and start
telling jokes that were so unfunny and
you had to know when to laugh you know
because he was solid about for example
on the Fuhrer is so cold and mr. Newman
who's Paul Newman had to eat his
asparagus with gloves because everybody
knows you you know it was a gourmet
thing you eat asparagus with your hands
it was so cold you got to eat but and so
it was supposed to laugh you know he's
not funny Hitchcock was it like it
intimidating you're a young guy at that
point isn't intimidating to step on to a
set or work for somebody of hitch
Hitchcock's caliber this I mean people
of course know you've worked on jaws and
like Spielberg what's he like but he was
a kid when he worked to them by the time
you worked with Hitchcock he had been
Hitchcock for many years is it
intimidating to work with a figure yeah
it was and there were three people there
was a high head Croft was a productive
manner for Germany because he was going
to do the ballet sing and Frank Arrigo
was was the art work I was the assistant
so I don't you know in the chain but
they're both away and Peggy his sister
calls me said mr. Hitchcock wants to
talk to you me yes
so I go up it won't believe this carrot
and he he used to be an art director you
know is that how he began really yeah he
was an art director in England before he
was director so he could speak your
language well yeah he started to draw
this thing at but the pencil never left
the table it just kept like a worm
crawling and he said okay no mr. Newman
comes here runs day
the stairs you build the stairs mr. al
Whitlock is going to do the math shot
then mr. Newman comes down and goes
after the registration desk and leaves
and I said how about the reverse shot
how about there no no no he you only
built what he was going to shoot
we never go believe me half sets because
that was Hitchcock so he knew going in
his plan was such that he didn't need
four walls were it sounds like even
three in some cases no Kevin he was so
prepared it was boring for him to shoot
I mean it's like yeah we built half sets
I mean it could be an incredible set you
know but it'd be he did do a reverse so
he knew he wasn't gonna do the reverse
and so why you know I have built huge
sets for directors then never shot him
alright
heartbreaking you didn't have that
problem but yeah but you know what I
mean yeah they want everything and then
they figure out what yeah Alan Rickman
once told me the actor he was like if
you could ever see the Harry Potter sets
he's going you would lose your mind
because they are so insanely detailed
and then you go see the movie and
there's one big wide shot and then they
move on and you don't spend the time
just looking at the production value he
said that was just built into it it's
insane he says him and the actors would
stand around and just take it all in and
all I had a thing for the second and I'm
not going to talk about the director
he's a nice enough guy but I built this
huge fort for Geronimo mm-hmm and you
know Geronimo is coming in and there's
the Disraeli
Tetons back here or whatever but then
you turn this way and there's a huge set
I kept waiting
when's he going to reverse when he's
there we had to the re-enactors and you
know the major actors there but and he'd
ever did a reverse he never only you're
thinking so anyway you're like all that
money all that
time all that effort all that artistry
just turn the camera buddy
just once and I kept that yawning it was
a camera director of photography I said
when she got in when we put I don't know
I'm a heartbreak of a production
designer when do you get the how do you
get the gig on Sugarland Express because
it sounds like you'd been working a lot
longer than Steven at that point well
yeah let me what happened I met Steven
on night gallery retro and I get three
three different years so when did you
were you with him on the one with Joan
Crawford that he did no that was the
pilot I wasn't in that position yet I
was still starting and if we did the
pilot and then we did a couple episodes
of a thing called the psychiatrist it
was a television series I think it were
six episodes so then when he got he dual
he used somebody staff guy and then he
was looking for somebody for Sugarland
and the production manager said what you
need is a young Franco vehicle Franco
Rico was my mentor and so Stevens oh
yeah I know Joe you know he'd be fine so
the studio didn't even think we needed
an art director cause was off on the
road but it was amazing because we just
found stuff on the road you know to
shoot and make it better you know we
just things would come up
let's talk about that real quick in
terms of for those who don't understand
the job when you said it's a road movie
so there probably wouldn't be much
production design for those who don't
follow this closely in film if you're
building a veer on a set obviously
that's where Joe thrives he has to build
that world that you're gonna shoot on
right if you go out into the real world
suddenly you're relying more on things
as they naturally occur or location this
building exists we'll just use this
building and then you have to set deck
it and things but the job gets a little
bit easier at that point oh good
no no well anyway because on sugar land
we didn't have
location guy you know at all look no and
so I went out and scouted I remember
getting on a helicopter and looking for
in Texas I wanted a road there what
forever this way and the road that went
forever that way and then I built a huge
sign which a lot of different roads and
so Stephen Pam down there so you find
that kind of thing you fly around fly
around and we scouted from Sugar Land to
we ended up in San Antonio finding
locations and and modifying them so it
was you know I thought if I found a road
but the road didn't look good I tended
the damn road you know you know because
of what a nice clean road and it was
interesting because Stephen was like his
first feature bill Gilmore was the
production manager and what we would do
is we were riding the three of us well
we had a driver and Bill would say well
this locations not good it's too far
away from our base you know it takes an
hour and a half to get in power you lose
three hours a day so you want to keep
something closed I remember one time I
said stops you know we drove down a hill
and I said there's a road up here I said
you could get all the lines of cars here
and Goldie would be up here and then
they pulled down and you shoot this and
then bill would say yeah and we're only
thirty five minutes away so we got back
and Stephen said this is sort of naive
at the time he says gosh I feel like I'm
stealing from you guys you know young
you know and I said no no see that's
what I do is give you information you
take it or you leave it and bill said
yeah that's we're here to support you
and I think because then Stephen
realized he had a team he wasn't off
just making a movie by himself which you
probably experienced as you started and
put you how you find a team and you
could rely on them to go out and find
something for you and then you can look
at it that works or maybe it doesn't
work you know Papa bucks so that's how
we grew and at this point and Sugar Land
this is like he had done duel already
but yes was a big deal for him like this
was like a
like all this this might put me on the
map so to speak as a studio filmmaker
yeah and you had Goldie who was the
sweetest thing in the world I got I
don't you never worked it above loved
her mala she's just so sweet and I
thought he did really a good job but the
picture really never what crazy you know
and so much so that like was that a
universal show yeah so based on that
like well I guess who is that while he's
working on that or right after that is
when somebody's like hey there's this
Cha's book when did it come into your
guys lives well okay without going into
a big detail zanuck and Brown were the
producers heavyweights sure they you
know the sting Butch Cassidy David
Brown's wife Helen Gurley Brown was the
editor of Cosmopolitan he was New York
[ __ ] and Dave and dick was la base she
said to David I just rent a galley she
to this book first time director writer
called jaws she says I think would make
a good movie David called me and said
Joe you know if you have time they don't
have a charge number so they couldn't
pay me you know because it wasn't even
real yet it was it was that even
purchased the books of exactly so he
said could you while you're doing you
know whatever go through the galleries
and do maybe you know 30 drawings you
know 11 by 16 I could sure they're in
the book they're there charcoal ones
rough ones and so I did about 30 of
those and I would I talked to the head
of the art department and I said I'm
doing a television movie and there was a
lot of location says so I'd go check
them out in the morning
everything's fine I go back and I start
drawing I'm sure you know and I'm as an
art director you're only supposed to do
a limited amount of drawings and they're
supposed to hire an illustrator but
there's no charts no but they couldn't
hire anybody I went to there and and he
said zanuck about just do it you know
you know there I mean there were like
these kind of drawings and where are you
getting reference for sharks like
nowadays one would go to the internet
find it and stuff
this was great him Blin when the book
came out sharks weren't really even part
of the public consciousness yet I if you
look at those early things sometimes it
looks like Moby Dick I didn't get into
studying them until there was an OK to
do it and then I got with a neck
theologist from the Steinhardt in San
Francisco
Leonard kept an yo and I did a four foot
model clay model and he came down with
me and we detailed every D so the shark
was like right on you know there's no I
mean I was working with a topic
theologist and he he was there playing
with the clay no the nose is this you
know so so we got it like right on you
know Kevin dead and then I really
started talking with Ron and Valerie
Taylor who did through the Australians
who shot the underwater for really nice
people and they advised me a lot about
the movement of the shark and stuff like
that so all right so this Oh anyway so
that was I would go over talk to Steve
it I see what I'm doing them to sink
they don't have a director yet you know
blah blah and we was talking he was
gonna do a pirate movie or something he
said yeah Joe if we do this because we
we don't want to do it in a backlog lake
you know with a phony background we're
gonna do the big shark
maybe 25 feet in the real ocean I said
yeah that's what we're gonna do right at
least so we're very enthusiastic a
little naive could nobody ever done that
before you know and so basically they
had a director in mind but he kept
calling it away all the year so I guess
in the world most even you know and
basically so that he came aboard so
technically you were on Jaws even before
Stephen was on jaws Yeah right well when
I first hear the word jaws
you know I just think of a period in my
life when I was much younger than I am
right now and I think because I was
younger I was more courageous or where I
was more stupid I'm not sure which so
when I think of jaws I think about
courage and stupidity and I think of
both of those things existing underwater
so when he jumps on you've already shown
him like look at the stuff I'm drawn and
whatnot he's drawn into the idea of like
this is a Moby Dick story but with the
shark yeah I kept showing him you know
the illustrations but but then Marshall
Greene who was a head of production
mm-hmm who just happened to live on a
boat so he really liked this but the
studio didn't want to do this movie is
that ready now they didn't want to do a
dumb shark movie even they're going to
spend four million tops so Marshall said
let's have a meeting I remember exactly
it was October 3rd because I kept a
little piece from the lady that at the
desk it said three ten o'clock meeting
with Marshall Green's office Monday
October 3rd 1973 so they had all the
department heads the head of camera has
a 13 head of effects and our art
department and zanuck at Brown and the
young Spielberg was there and so it was
a big group in Marshall's office at the
top of the black tower and so I went
through the spiel and the shark does
this the shark does that nobody you know
and I kept showing the drawings and then
worship said okay and he pointed to the
effects Department and said okay guys
how about it can you make it Andy and
cuz we figured 25 foot sir they said no
we can't make a shark I mean it's never
been done nobody's ever made a shark and
shot it in the real ocean and no he said
it would take a year year and a half and
they said besides we have a bigger
important movie going to Hindenburg uh
you know I mean all that movie in the
theaters yeah and Marshall got really
upset with lambda he said jaws could be
a bigger movie than the Hindenberg and
everybody in the room sort of laughed
you know because this was short see
Scott who's going to beat this who's
gonna make this little shark movie all
right so basically just everybody left I
was collecting my joins I started to
walk out and where I'll call me back and
he said can you get the shark mate and
I'm thinking you know young ambitious
right yeah I'll try
yeah okay so all right he said but take
it out of the studio don't do it on the
studio so which is her everything was
done in-house right off the pot find an
independent guy and after much trial and
errors Joe Lombardi his Godfather he's a
cog Joey would take the year you'd have
to make its number but does but I got
some other projects I went to Disney
they said yeah they could make it but
that won't take her to the ocean and
then somebody says there was this guy
Bob Manny he did the giant squid in
20,000 Leagues Under the Sea
worked at Disney's for years I met him
and he talked about how he could do it
and in the book there's a little sketch
okay he said I'll be back in a couple
days came back with his wire thing you
pull this thing and it goes like that
I'd pull it back and mouth opens close I
said good okay so he could make it and
then we said we need some people we need
a guy that knows of me plastics the new
two forever guess we found him making
breakaway bottles and yeah there's new
last summer's and stuff you know and we
found people that there did the
photographer mean they the electronics
you know and all that so we'll put it
together of a six guys I call them the
Magnificent's everywhere and seven guys
story so that's how it started how long
did it take to build that shark everyone
was like it'll take a year or two years
how long till you this is okay so that
would be probably by the time we got the
team together would be November middle
November towards the end December of 73
the
came out February 70 February 74 oh my
god you guys had a shark you were
working on the shark before the book
Street no so we started working on it
and then February the the book came out
and the studio said we're gonna start
this movie shooting this movie into two
months and I said we can't do it two
months and then Spielberg said well give
us three months so anyway that was May
so that was like five months not a year
and a half and so Bob got he tries that
you didn't the water would get the
electronics just eat it up
we tested things who would work and then
you've got there's this thing about the
shark doesn't work so then I would go to
Bob I said we have three sharks left to
right right to left and the one on the
platform mmm the big crane with a gimbal
with an arm that could gather them and
that was on a big platform that we could
sink and I'll tell you how that works in
the location that I found so I would go
to Bob I said what do you think's work
and he says I think the left-to-right is
working I go to Stephen and I say I
think the looked right now while I was
there I you know we needed storyboards
they didn't want to pay to have a
storyboard artists coming but Joe could
do it just don't tell anybody I'm doing
like they're all in the book probably
two or three words and we'll go skinny
went left right and he'd say okay we'll
do 183 a B and C tomorrow so everybody
would prepare so I said and if it
doesn't work it's a test but if it works
you shoot it and basically that's the
way it went you know and and only one
comment I have to make because I got the
critics probably crazy on this is that
we didn't use the shark because it
didn't know and we use the bear house
and said totally wrong if you see
there's barrels in the early early
sketches based on the book the barrels
or a Hitchcock kind of thing - Stephen
wanted to do you know what I mean Kevin
- yeah barrel comes it goes down
cranny if it barrels there what's there
the shortage pot it tells the story more
so than it sells a better story than
just showing the shark its terror you
see the boat and boom boom they pop up
right yeah so that was you know that
wasn't planned at that point like you
see the storyboard so the critics saying
oh it didn't work gherkin works and
that's why they did that
not at all believing everything every
shot shark we planned that's in the book
there we got you know the what was the
the for those that don't follow the
story that closely when they got the
shark to Martha's Vineyard because you
guys built it we're out here in
California yeah here's what happened in
Sunland Roni Harper was a caterer
service and they had a big lot in a big
warehouse so we based there and they
started making the three sharks there as
they got him somewhat finished they
shipped him to Martha's Vineyard know
one thing about Martha's Vineyard and
all that by myself in the winter looking
for a beaches that were covered with
snow and I met Peter Benchley in New
York and I said so Peter where did you
write this for said well there was sank
harvest over ten Menemsha different but
nothing specific much except he said
[Music]
Nantucket my parents live there
Nathaniel Benchley isn't he he said go
go see them and go look at that Tucket
my wife will make you cucumber and cream
cheese sandwiches so basically I left
and I started scouting not only did I
want we want Stephen and we went in a
quaint village kind of thing but we also
needed a location to shoot the shark and
there was a barge and then it would sink
and we needed 25 feet of depth so when
it raised it was you know perfect height
but we needed also a small tide you know
in the West Coast tides like 12 14 feet
so I'm scouting all over and I come I
end up in locked down in Woods Hole and
I take the boat to Nantucket but it was
such rough weather they turned around so
then there was a boat - was his vineyard
and I asked Peter about Mars he said now
there's nothing much but he'd never been
there he's an island guy doesn't go
enough boat - what's his vineyard and I
started scouting and I I saw you know
vineyard haven I saw you know the you
know the various towns and they were
perfect Menemsha you know and so
Edgartown and but in between there was
this bay with an open view of the ocean
it was 25 feet with a two-foot tide so
that that's why you guys chose Martha's
Vineyard it was perfect for the
boardwalk for the aunt and for Edgar
town was perfect in row and Menemsha for
a Quincy place so that's how that came
about I brought Steven there and zanuck
was not too crazy about it for two
reasons the Menemsha has the the thing
not whenever the thing with ted kennedy
yeah it's a pivot and a lot of rich
people live there right and then he
didn't want a movie being shot there was
that is that true so the local community
did they welcome you guys and they were
like uh no Steven was smart he hired all
the selectmen and put them in a movie I
took a painter and a carpenter and that
was my crew in a set decorator and I
built quit shack
I built the boats too you know we did a
boat rebuild look all with locals so
they were really excited to get this
work but small yeah rich people but
there's people that aren't rich that
live there that have you know summer
jobs and stuff like that so it worked
out yeah we didn't really have any
complaints you know I mean I almost hit
water at Walter Cronkite's boat alter
many years later some producer knew him
he came into a movie I was doing it was
a really nice guy and he said yeah Joe I
know I said he said we used to get out
and sneak around watch you guys shoot
you know but it didn't seem to bother
him right
how long were you guys originally as
most of the stories tell us you were
originally supposed to be there for a
certain amount of time and then the
shoot just kept extending were you there
the whole time and Martha's Vineyard I
was there I was my job became
coordinating between Bob Matty and
Steven this bob was sort of hard to talk
to you asked him are you gonna start
going to work tomorrow and he'd start
telling you
well the RAM thing was a cell phone or
didn't and the thing didn't go and blood
all of that and I said but is it going
to work tomorrow well that depends on so
Steven said just go talk to Bob right
you were the bob was burger
so to speak and then I'd go to Steven
okay and then every time the shark was
there I would be on on board you know
and but what happened was we shot
everything we could
without the shark you know everybody
walk and talk the things you could do we
get some barrels we did whatever Vernon
feels and I were doing something in
Gerald's burn the fields for those that
don't follow closely enough is the
editor that's mother cutter right so
she's building me Warren
won the Academy Award and she's building
the movie while they're shooting the
movie for those that don't follow that
closely
cutting a movie while you're shooting a
movie ensures that you're gonna find out
who we might need this who we didn't
miss this let's get this he's great
she
big Kim a big Kim photochemistry yeah
yeah you know and she had my storyboards
there I've never seen a director editor
do that with there was no ego about this
thing
you know it was we were working together
there were like six of us that really
believed in the movie the other people
were crew hard-working crew but the
production manager you know Steven burna
myself and so if I remember we had the
Kim and we had some tests and we had Ron
and Valerie Taylor on the phone and
Valerie to say Joe you know you're
moving the tail too much
the shark is big he does founders
through until he wants to attack
something so you know I was getting an
expert opinion about how and the first
shot we got of the shark going by the
boat you know and you see how big it is
yeah and it just moved
perfectly it just we didn't go like this
we just and that was wrong and Valerie
Taylor his advice you know to do that
and so for the for the sequence like
Ronon and Valerie Taylor shot underwater
footage of actual sharks with a smaller
guillotine there with it with the team
did you go for the Australia they did
that over there by themselves no let me
explain what happened there we had Tom
Wright was a really good illustrator he
was at the studio so we now in charge
someone so he did sketches of what was
going to go there he also did all the
paintings for Knight tower he was great
well anyway we did a team prank my
mentor or ego could was the producer
weirdo but what we what Valerie told us
is that the biggest shark we're going to
get is 16 feet hmm
which jaw in the movie we 25 already
know we found a stunt guy who is about
four feet six and I made a small cage
you know because it's this is where he's
goes up with Dreyfuss character goes
down the keys and sharks that hit him
so this guy said oh yeah he's a diver
either so you know people said he would
ever they could do anything to get the
job yeah there's a whole bicycle
sequence but they don't know how to ride
a bike I have a Don Jose to the kids you
know how to swim yes when that's not is
the sequence and he doesn't know how to
swim until we get there right here
you've got this kind of yes so anyway so
I had to make a small tank everything
scaled down so they got there they had a
full-size breakaway cage on the side of
the boat but then they said there's the
small one down he gets in there and the
16-foot shark comes and he freaks out he
sucks all the air out they have to pull
him out and he goes and hides it says
he's not going back again are you giving
me really really but the crew was under
there shooting and while that is
happening the real shark goes after the
cage that's just oh and it gets caught
in the cage that's in the movie but
there's no Dreyfuss so everybody says
because Dreyfuss supposed to get eaten
right look so they said no we got we
gotta use that that's this great shot
and I know I could never get any shots
of the shark going a wave because we'd
have all the mechanism seen you know so
we needed a couple not too many but a
couple real short run anyway it was
that's so great so anyway what happens
is the shark attacks Dreyfuss character
goes down in Heights right and he lives
so that was so basically that footage
that Ron and valor is shot changed the
subject change the script that's wild
man that's right because he dies Hooper
dies in the book yeah but he did great
when they come up together and then they
you know there's some yeah all right so
so all throughout the production of the
flick it was the trial and error because
nobody had ever done anything like this
before you've reached out to Bob because
he had done the octopus in 20,000
leagues but
nobody had how did they represent sharks
and movies prior to Jaws because they
didn't do what animated a lot of stock
footage I guess right you know so the
form that the one that they built that
you guys build all three of them are
made of what kind of is it foam or is it
Oh Noel Kate first of all if you look
there was a thing here it was really a
technical I think I think I would just
okay you see that yes oh my god I see
that in my dreams that's what heaven
looks like okay you see all the inner
work yes and that's the one on the crane
thing and then so it has a full
structure and then there's layers a foam
that does it absorb water and this
different last summer's and stuff and
then we painted it with a number 40 so
silica sand so it wouldn't you know go
off like that this is the the framework
to start with to make the mold and
anyway it's it was a big deal so and
nobody had ever built like a monster
know that right no there's a Disney
build some stuff just he had built okay
they have build stuff but they shot it
in a tank right
so sharks have been made and whales
there was a whale killer whale I think
you know Disney had done something like
that but but not in the real ocean and
that was and so going into it you got I
mean this is all trial and error it's
all theoretical until you get the actual
unit to the ocean like did they test
them in a pool before they went to
Martha's Vineyard no time we had no kind
of a test there was no testing in other
words we start shooting we started in
May but mid-june okay that gives Bob
maybe six seven months not a year and a
half
so we started shooting whatever was
available to shoot and it kept
rehearsing the other problem we had
kevin is when I scouted that Bay it was
in December come July September or
August
Vienna Sport is there and all the big
boats are coming Oh even was to his that
Steven was so firm that he wanted to see
nothing out there
these guys were alone that's why they
broke the radio radio and so we were
there and the studio we go crazy because
why is it the kid shooting because
there's boats out there would send
runners out could you move the book and
some people would cooperate then there
would be asses you know no no so he
whenever we did a master shot he wanted
nothing out there and I gotta tell he
was strong-willed is amazing you know
because of the pressure not like doing
some independent thing you've got a
major studio there and so and it's
something that today would they
digitally erase any boats on the horizon
digitally erased so on the second jaws
movie I was doing thing Close Encounters
and I would go out of Pensacola with
this girl that had greyhound dog did run
on Sunday and and it was just huge
Bailey ocean and nobody on it and I said
kind of whoever do it jaws to this is
where we're gonna shoot the ocean like
that back and they started jaws - so we
did establishing shots in Martha's
Vineyard and then we went to Navarro
Beach Florida
that was a cleaner view of the horizon
yeah and then we you know we had a shark
we had worked you know so but then this
on that one the studio wanted shark
after shark I I directed 85 days the
second unit of sharp stuff was killer
they so they wanted as much shark as
possible and that you know you know and
I gotta tell you you realize it was
Steven went through you sitting on a
boat for hours waiting for to get the
shot I mean it drives you crazy
is this working no we've gotta cut
cameras not saying you know
love-love uh and you're sitting here
right I mean and you're waiting yes it's
you literally can't do anything about it
like if an actor is late you can go to
their trailer and be like get over there
if some other crafts person on set is
like dropping the ball you could yell at
them replace them but you cannot do
anything about the real world no you're
out you're out there in the ocean and of
course you go you shoot this out of the
boat the water looks one way you shoot
that side it looks the other way it's
hard to you know Verna was ever quite
crazy yeah how does one match and
cutting oh my god what a nightmare so
wait so wait while this is going on and
everybody's you know like I would
imagine at a certain point start
fretting for their jobs and whatnot what
is the mood like on set particularly for
the Magnificent Seven or the or the core
group of people that believed the of
course affects guys works seven days a
week do you know 24 I mean they were
working 1213 hours they never had a day
off so I mean their focus was to get
that done the crew was getting buggy you
know they they just wanted to get away
and well and when we got back to the
studio
we were not heroes we were over budget
over schedule this shark movie was going
to kill us we're gonna have a career
it's so crazy yeah but you guys aren't
the hindenburg so it's gonna be it's
gonna ruin your careers was there of
like like was it a minute before you got
your next gig or was Stephen like we're
gonna go on and do this thing
no because after jaws that's even have
this idea of doing this movie we went
skiing we got we're up in a condo friend
of my dicks mother said of Condor it and
we were talking about being alone then
you start talking about dr. Hynix book a
UFO scientific enquiry with a person
kind of the first kind second circle I
said wow that sounds more interesting
that sounds like a great thing so he
didn't do being along John Badham called
me a week or two later said oh I'm doing
being along I said I guess Stephen stuff
but I did
called embryo with Rock Hudson small
movie mmm
didn't go to place and and then circle
and I mean then close encounter for some
gun and I was the only person I once
scouted that by myself you know and wait
so did you go find Devil's Tower
oh yeah that was you I drove 3,000 miles
looking I got a big map of scenic USA
and I drove to
shipra chimney rock arches all these guy
would too you know the president's the
backside of that South Dakota and then I
ended up to this thing I couldn't
believe the devil's tower so looks like
that it must have looked like a movie
poster when you saw it like because
that's what it because interesting
because you drive you see this little
shape and then you just disappears and
then the next time you come up then it's
bigger and then it disappears it then
you come up and my god and so at that
time you know you had 35 millimeter film
I took pan shots and then I got back
home and I put him on the illustration
boards all over and then Steven looked
down he says there's no question it was
that so it was in the material the
script the book or whatever like this
mountain structure or something yeah
just a strange Mountain strange Brown oh
my god found a better strange mountain
than that the head of production at
Columbia said Joe we're gonna shoot
everything on on there on the back lot
and on the studio but we need some
location one location a weird mountain
so cool off and there was nobody working
on the movie yet you know same damn
thing so I'm out driving by myself for
3,000 miles looking for a month do you
know do you know how amazing that is
like think about if what for you was the
beginning of a job where you're like I
have to go out in location scout this
and then you find something that has
captured people's imaginations for was
40 years since Close Encounters and like
and that goes the same with the shark
like you imagined for people this
incredible vision that they have taken
with them forever and just the sight of
devils tower fellows one with a sense of
like oh my god a happy childhood I
remember seeing that movie I remember
how breakthrough that was ain't so
perfect wasn't it was it so wait did you
duplicate the top of the mountain no the
only thing I duplicated and this is
today's it would be all green screen
right but when Dreyfuss and Belinda's
ill and climb up tonight I built seven
story my section of the mountain on
rollers so we could shoot in front of a
125 foot front projection screen oh my
god and so they climbed up that and then
Doug Trumbull was doing the effects and
then he photographed the big set you
know so when they climb up and you see
the big set so he shot that in 65 so we
wouldn't lose a definition you know 35
so yeah I just have the one rollers so
you know it was a huge seven stories on
rollers so we could and today you could
Google you know you do green screen and
finding the location would be googled
and you know you just get giddy
mountains weird mountains in you google
it right and true back in the day had to
be somebody out there going to find it
and then bringing that idea back to the
director it's so like and that should it
be illustrative for those listening like
with all due respect like I'm a director
so with all due respect to directors you
can see how the most important key
elements of a movie don't even sometimes
start with the director starts to the
director turning to somebody like Joe
going what do you think what would that
look like
can you draw that for me can you go find
this for me and then it becomes a fabric
of part of the fabric of the
storytelling you know it's interesting I
quoted because I had a an occasion to do
a little speech recently I was talking
about Rod Serling
I was talking to rod we were sitting
there Jewish work and was in Victor a
segment was and I said
how do you do that you wrote all those
Twilight Zone you read all that
nightgown
he looked at me said Joe I write the
words but you make them happen hmm and I
thought about that we do take the words
right nothing I mean without a script we
got nothing but you take that and it
says a mountain okay
well it means nothing until you go find
it and execute it you know and but that
was I was blown away he's a young guy
and Rod Serling's telling me that IRA I
write the words but you you make it
happen is this me maybe an older guy
there's a smarter guy he knew what he
was talking about we had a number of
different shark components we had the
full shark which I called the great
white turd which kind of we you know we
pulled along in the water and it was
often on this huge gantry like a crane
arm and it was when it was if the crane
arm was tucked all the way at the 30
foot bottom you couldn't see the shark
when the crane arm as quickly as they
could blow the ballast and and force the
arm out of the water the shark would
rise out of the water the truck could be
gimballed separately on the arm to have
an attitude change at the top of the of
the crane arm we had that we had just a
fin that was pulls of the water
[Music]
and we had a left to right shark and
right to left shark and the left to
right shark of course had no left side
it was all scooped out and the vice
versa for the other shark so wait so let
me ask you this so so many of us our
childhoods ruined by jaws and as much as
like I won't go near the water and stuff
how do you like did you ever have shark
nightmares did the how deep did the
shark embed into your psyche back in the
day because of course your relationship
goes beyond just jaws goes to jaws too
and jaws 3 as well so for a while you
were you were synonymous sharks yeah
yeah yeah well I
yeah it became because it was a physical
thing of getting and made how we're
gonna shoot at were location I mean I
had a lot of problems when I directed
and the Landsberg was cheap and let me
ask you this have you ever done a movie
where you didn't have final cut oh no no
you know and you make a movie there's
two hours and they cut it by 25 minutes
oh but you know I'm here to tell you as
a fan I paid cash money see jaws 3 in a
theater and I was not unhappy
I love jaws 3 it was still a part of the
world jaws is one of the only film
series before the Marvel movies where
there's a continuity and a world and
characters carried over so much so that
in 3 you're still dealing with Brody
kids and even in 4 they were dealing
with Brody kids so I love that stuff in
a big bad way but I wasn't
have you ever done 3d never never drives
you crazy you know it's a really and
it's such a good idea to the idea of
like the shark in the park that gets
flooded and everybody kind of trapped it
was a really cool idea so for so were
you were you ever scared sharks are you
worried one day you're gonna be eaten by
sharks
I was doing this something up in the
ocean floating around and it made me
think about that oh my god there's
sharks here and I just walked back to
shore that was basically it
yeah there are in shark attacks you know
there's no question about that white
shark they they gently don't go after
people they will throw in a surfboard
they think it's a seal mm-hmm
but I think they like seals better than
people the when jaws to happen now you
guys are making jaws and the studio's
like oh this movie it's gonna kill us
and then of course it becomes jaws how
quickly did they then say do it again
because again this is at a time when
sequels weren't de-rig or it wasn't the
standard what happened was I was
finishing Close Encounters I came back
to the studio because Close Encounters
it was Columbia but I went and and they
contacted me he's Anika Brown and said
we're doing jaws 2 and John Hancock is
the director and they're rewriting it
and blah blah blah so I Steven wanted me
to do something else what was he doing
at that time
and I had the choice of going with
Steven and I said was annex and well
we'll let you do all the second unit
because I did do some second unit on
jaws I did a little shot with him short
getting the kid on the raft oh my god
that shot with it with the we see the
outline of him underwater and then you
guys cut away just before I did the
thing where their kids flow down and
raft and shark up and grasp it beautiful
and Steven was he really wanted to get
back here it was exhausted and I said he
said just this could you cook at that so
I did it was kids playing anyway so
zanuck said we'll make you second in a
director make you a producer so two
producer and production designer so I
went to Stephen and he said I'll give
you the same thing I said well good I'll
go with you because we're buddies and he
said I don't have a deal
all right all right yeah you know
Hollywood without a deal use nothing
until you have a deal it's true it's
only an idea and somebody's have until
there's a paperwork you know indict
David or you know Joe you got to do this
for us you know blah blah blah and it's
also you are the you are the key
component at that point like for many of
course you know jaws does not happen
with Steven Spielberg but if you trace
it all the way back like you know you
are the shark guy you know they in order
to make a successful jaws movie they
have to turn just people who are
involved in the first one and be like
you did it do it again so it makes sense
that they reach out to you yeah put the
team together and then of course they
had a problem with Hancock and he left
or was it Jen what was the guy's name
replaced if you know she work I got him
the job in this respect that he did 23
episodes of Night Gallery we were very
close and we had a lot of young
directors John Badham and and you have
no preparation when you're doing a
three-day shoot you have you know so
it's pretty much your sucess this is
this so you know with most directors
they say okay fine was you know he
seemed to find a better way of doing it
than I had planned you know pretty
clever you know he shot what I but he so
I thought they needed a director I said
what - Verna feels she's no vice
president I said this guy should know
and he did a movie called bug or
something so anyway they they were going
to shut it down they're going to just
cancel it out and nan Tannen was the
president that Ned can calm yourself he
said uh so we're gonna shut down I said
well I talked about the races or you and
Verna wanna direct it and I said well
that's not a bad idea but the Directors
Guild wind let us do that you know you
can't fire somebody and like they could
take a cameraman fire the director and
he could take over that was a no-no as
such a shame because of the of anyone
involved with the production
you've early I would have you were
tempered in and steel you were there for
the megamix she would know what we
needed to cut we want to know it would
have been perfect anyway so I then I
mentioned as you know so then he came by
and then we changed the location to
Florida and I think Bill Gilmour
wouldn't shut some third unit with
Scheider and Lorraine driving around
is that right the boat so they shot jaws
to down Florida yeah wow I didn't know
that we had we made things look like the
east coast but locations and but we shot
so much footage I mean so much shark
stuff I'd sit on the boat
hours maybe I'd get you know all day and
get maybe two shots you know grueling
I'm a dialogue man so if we're not
shooting dialogue I feel like we you
know oh we've lost our way and lost time
and on a movie like that dialogue is
secondary you're trying to get the
beautiful shots I got a shot where the
sharp each the helicopter yeah I love
that shot
I said that's in the script and we had
Carl got me on one two and three you
know brought Carl back love Carl we're
good friends anyway so I started a shark
and helicopter then I saw this little
helicopter with the pontoons and I said
boy they're char could go after that it
looked like two you know two seals up
there so Kevin we get there and you have
to anchor the helicopter you have to
anchor the effects barge you have to
anchor the camera barge right and is
this cable Junction real or do you have
to build that in the water like the
island that I below so that's not even a
real island no I built that oh my god so
ed none of its real you went out in the
ocean no it was all yeah we just had a
big bay out there
so anyway I'm doing it I'm doing that
charge and so I said okay fine you know
it's the seventh or eighth you get out
there by 11 you got everything
you're ready to go and the shark goes
and he turns and it hits the camera boat
and that's it he's done oh my god hey
second date all right get to helicopter
going gets the shark card the helicopter
flips over and breaks all the things in
the water yeah so we have to that's a
cut
put new blades on their third day
finally fingers spinning the hell sharp
desert takes it down it was perfect shot
but three days no you you go crazy to
get that shot yeah
what is the you know when when we think
of the modern-day blockbuster it traces
all the way back to Jaws the first event
film as they say something that you know
of instant summer movie and whatnot what
is it feel like to play such an integral
part in that legacy like you know no
it's it's not just like oh I drew a
shark once like you created jaws for
heaven's sakes
well Kevin you know the industry is very
unforgiving you you know I never okay
first of all we thought they were gonna
laugh at the shark because it would make
funny noises and the crew laughter we
cut and then we had the screening and
they didn't last they screamed I said
they opened with all the executives
there Lew Wasserman him I said Tate they
opened its 450 theaters well I recall
this big which was a huge huge opening
then so it became a big success but that
didn't mean that much to me at the time
yeah it was a big success
but what's the next job the next job is
very important and and it goes on that
way your career so then I did just to
know where John's movies and then I was
doing a thing called the ninja director
remember see and I was on that for seven
months and that got cancelled oh my god
put in that much time and then why not
have there be a product got a history of
that
of movies that and and then Verna says
oh there's this guy television guy that
bought jaws three and blah blah blah so
then I got involved with that but you
know it was like then then after three
you know as director I trying to get
directing gigs and you know how that
goes you you know I I had one gig I was
doing I was on it for seven months and
then the money fell out and another one
i scattered all over europe and that got
back i was going to do a racing movie
and everything and and that got back in
the company folded somebody else bought
him him so anyway I didn't think about
jaws until probably this century went to
a reunion right Terrell kept calling me
and I came from a lot of and and and
people said oh you you should show your
storyboards copies of your SOI so I do a
Joelle's Willie art calm so all that's
done beautiful and so all those years I
never really thought about it until this
century when there's these fan base
things I start doing these shows you
know you did kappa con is definitely
shoot in New Jersey that's the thing
that was missing when you guys made the
movie was fandom because that's what you
guys created was fandom you created an
army of people that loved the movie so
much they can quote it backwards and
forwards they want to see where it was
shot and whatnot so you watched over the
course of your career your position go
from unsung to like you can walk into
like a jaws fest or a comic-con and
people like you're a rock star but look
okay you're you're born in 70 so you're
like 49 gonna be 50 am gonna be 50 Greg
Nicotero was 56 Dennis Prinz who wrote
the book is 55 so suddenly these guys
you know that age are successful yeah
and then they look at it oh wow what a
great thing we did
and I'm thinking I've been retired you
know for 20 years I mean I'm very busy I
do a lot of sculptors I'm very happy but
like in the end the guy who wrote this
book is a big Josh fan and he said you
know I wrote to you back in the 80s and
you signed it to a shark or a million
blah blah blah so it's enough it's
interesting but it's you guys that are
making it yeah but it's it's basically
it's akin to what Serling said or told
you years ago it's like you guys dreamed
it like we consumed it and that bred a
generation of storytellers who were like
I want to do that and none of us will
ever make jaws but you know some get
close like you know like with Greg you
know he does his prosthetics and then he
became a director as well and he if
there's anybody in this world loves jaws
his Greg I mean you've seen like his the
back of the Orca and stuff like that I'm
sure oh you know and you look at he did
their forward he writes about on the
book it's a great guy and he's he's so
busy now well he just need to live close
by and he's doing Creepshow he's writing
Creepshow yeah yeah I can't wait to see
that the the orcas let's talk about the
orcas real quick you said they were what
two or three orcas due to the story I've
always heard was that the one yet
Universal the tour was one of the boats
is that true yeah here's how smart the
studio is when we got back from the
studio from Jaws they threw the sharks
in the back let him rot oh my god they
sold the boat the Orca they sold it for
like almost nothing because somebody
wanted it some grip and they sold it and
then the jaws became a big success and
they wanted to make a shark
they made the out of the original mold
I'll get to that real quick anyway so
then they had to buy the Orca back but
that will we bought
beau Tom Joyner and Bob Mary I found it
in near for Massachusetts somewhere I
can't remember and then I totally
changed it Stephen wanted bigger windows
and I made it a real character open but
you know and try to make it give it sort
of a quince look to it you know painted
a dark wood and so it had a lot of
character so then Bob Madi needed a boat
to sink you know
so he made we made a fibreglass of the
same boat and with no bottom and then he
had all these barrels so he could turn
the barrels it would float but you
turned the barrels it sucked the waters
of then the boat good angle different
degrees right and so then that one got
broken up and and destroyed the other
the other thing I built was I built some
of the windows and the shark comes into
the cabin that was but yeah it was you
know and then so the studio they had
nothing so then they took any made a
fiberglass shark out of the original
mold and they hung it up
which I I took pictures with as a kid
yeah picture of Greg as a picture and
then somebody bought the got it and it
was any car lot it was a used car part
law called the junkyard shark right and
then if you see in the back of the book
it was restored correct Nicotero
restored it and I was approached by
somebody for NPR about ten years ago
corey turner and he wanted to do some
you know what's happening to shark and
so we went to look at it it was just not
too well you know they had wood teeth on
it and and I got Roy a Berg and he says
yeah this is made from the original mold
I could tell you know the claws and
everything so then a couple years after
that somebody called me from the museum
motion picture museum which they're
working on and she said we're gonna buy
it and can we get somebody to fix it up
so then I called Greg and Roy we went
and looked at he says yeah I could do it
so he's been working on it so now then I
went to the museum to see where it
should hang it and it's in the in the
book there Greg I mean it's perfect you
know so that's the lasting spark that is
that's the one that made it yeah the the
Orca story that I had heard about the
boat on the lot was on the JA you know
on the tram tour when you come to Amity
Island the work they had an orca that
was there for years yes and apparently
that was the one and they said that
since Amblin was there on the lot
spielberg periodically would go sit on
the boat because it was the boat that
changed his life like he spent you know
a formative time on that boat worried
about whether his career would work or
not and of course the boat made all the
difference in his career
then they said some Universal executive
at one point had gotten rid of the boat
did you ever hear this story yeah he
said what do we do with that old boat oh
they just broke it all up as I heard
they really flipped out about that
rightfully so like not only his personal
piece of history but like a piece of
film history it's the Orca for heaven's
sakes
yeah the executive probably had no
relationship with the movie or cared I
don't know any you know let's clean up
the backlog right the the the you said
you've been retired for like 20 years
now from the motion picture business but
now with I mean people have loved jaws
forever but now we live in the age of
fandom as you pointed out like you're
interacting more with jaws in this
century than you did in the last thing
oh because of the book yeah you know and
Dennis we first did a book on Close
Encounters
because Catalina Island I got to know
the lady runs the museum there and she
had a thing about Close Encounters so we
just self-published book Close
Encounters and but we have
lot of problems with with with this so
neon that I had the why let's see
Wyoming Park Commission flew me up to
Devil's Tower really nice lady and they
wanted to shoot a film of me finding the
tower and then they have me forty years
before then finding the tower and
talking and so and then I had pictures
of being Bill Mollison Steven and so
they did a documentary on that but Sony
said oh you can't use this picture and I
said that's my private pictures that's
my life really asked us about it so we
self-published it and never really you
know we didn't make a lot of money off
of it but what was funny is when we were
shooting Close Encounters and I put a
sign park clothes cuz then Dreyfuss runs
through there and climbs up the hill and
the Ranger said you can't close the park
closed in the park it's just for clothes
you know and then we'll take it off no
no you can't close the park he was
insistent so we couldn't put that side
and then forty years later now it's a
big thing come to you know Devil's Tower
because that's where they shot close at
cottage no doubt you put them on the map
for heaven's sakes um you are largely
responsible for why a lot of us grew up
to do what we did to work in this
business you dreamed our dreams for us
man you showed us our nightmares but you
captured our imagination and whether it
was in Jaws you know with a shark flying
onto a boat or whether it's in Jaws -
with a shark eating the pontoon on a
helicopter or whether it's in jaws 3
with shark goes right into the facility
and whatnot those those are all happy
childhood memories for me man up up
above my head if I tilt this screen up
you'll see way on the top shelf up there
there you go I see it
I know that jerk oh come on that's the
beautiful sideshow I think I've got a
lot of short pictures here I don't know
if you can see my oh yeah I mean that's
you you picture this
and different crew oh yeah this is Karl
it Dreyfus we did it I think there's a
show somewhere it is it's it's it looks
like an office that I would like to live
in sir it's got so many people yeah you
are the the book of course is called
designing jaws it's available right now
you can pick it up in Amazon jaws
celebrating its 45th anniversary with a
fat blu-ray with lenticular cover that's
out right now pick it up and whatnot I
again like I've watched it's ridiculous
to say like oh I just watched jaws
recently I watched jaws at least six
times a year so I just watched the new
version of its and when it came and it
absolutely not it's to say it holds up
as an understatement it's still the gold
standard to which many movies aspire to
and all movies steal from to this day
yeah I just want to say one thing please
do
last year two years ago Catalina had a
in their Museum six months of Jaws your
Greg brought a lot of his drawings I had
originals people say you can't put the
originals out the cost you know but I do
have I saved all the original storybook
anyway so then they had a big screen
outdoor at night they're honest there
and I wasn't going to sit down my wife
said yes [ __ ] you're gonna watch the
book I said I haven't seen it for a long
time but I had to you know the big
screen not it Kevin it was so long I
wasn't worried about the things I did or
if the short work and what I realized
was so good was Spielberg's directing
are the three guys yeah it was three
guys of different personalities the old
fisherman and the you know the etiology
smartass and the cops they didn't want
to be there right and then there's a
shark yes but that relationship really
made the movie don't you think oh
absolutely number one it is you spend
more time with people than you do with
the shark the shark is what gets you in
that's the sexy look what's a movie
about a shark that eats people then you
get inside and find out it's a movie
about three men thrown together in the
midst of this high adventure on the Seas
they're interrelated 'ti like you know
of course them having the conversation
about the USS Indianapolis oh yeah it
was great though that's them definitely
like the meat of that movie but what
gets everybody through the door is the
shark and if the shark doesn't work you
can't go on that adventure man you guys
made a shark that worked and so much so
that like you know no one will ever have
to do what you guys did again they'll
always do it on a laptop or some so [ __ ]
so changed it's a it's you know it was
like I did a I had an award show they
gave me uh the art directors came there
I was Lifetime Achievement yeah I was
just recently I was in February yeah and
what was a big surprise is they got
Steven to do a video and it was so
complimentary and you know he just the
relationship all these years and then he
was saying he still has never been on a
set as big as the one we did in Close
Encounters and he don't know the
relationship we had on John and so that
was so rewarding Kevin after all these
years to have a man of his stature who
just keeps making movies to not forget
you know what I mean that you know what
that's very true and it's it's sweet of
him and says a lot about his character
but it what matters is that you're an
unforgettable person who did
unforgettable work and one could easily
argue that Steven doesn't get to have
the career he gets unless he meets you
along the way you're a key component my
friend oh yeah what works both ways it
does it does I have I'm 49 I'm gonna be
50 in a couple months and I've been
watching this movie as we know it's been
out for 45 years I saw it in a drive-in
with my parents the summer that it came
down he still stays with me it's still
my all-time probably my
time favorite movie and not just you
know of course like it being an
adventure film it is captivating
particularly for a kid when you're a kid
you like what it's about a charm though
say I'm five years old I was thinking
you're to say showy you shot when you
were five yeah I was looking at there
was something else I found interesting
your father was born the same year I was
born
get out of here really 1936 yes my god
so that's right my dad would be 84
what's wait 84 my dad I am for this year
I wish 84 Thursday I know I thought
about that a poor man didn't have the
life oh he had he had a wonderful life
and he know what he did he took me to
the movies when I was a kid that was
great but I mean he obviously didn't
extend yeah he got to 67 you know his
heart took him out a little bit earlier
number got me you know I looked at I can
wait a bit you know and there so that
figure 70 so you were five so it was
just interesting
it's everything to me this movie and you
know the hearing I've always loved the
behind the scenes stories the stories of
it being made as a filmmaker it's
thrilling to hear about how like close
to the failure everyone was until it was
a success and whatnot so not only the
story itself jaws of the chief Brody you
know having to face a killer shark
coming to Amity captured my imagination
and heart but the stories of y'all
making it and how you put everything
into it and how it was incredibly
visionary because these things didn't
exist now we take for granted like I you
want to make a shark movie let's put a
shark in a movie you do that sort of
thing then and the entire industry the
the summer blockbuster industry built on
the very strong back of the spine of
that shark that you first started
drawing back in 1973 that is nuts man
yeah long time I think thanks to Bob
Mattie and forever gas and people like
that that just worked there oh my god so
hard you know they were the heroes
you're not taking nearly enough credit
Joe your hero as well if you haven't
seen jaws lately kids 45th anniversary
limited edition blu-ray is is the one to
pick up I saw cutscene scenes that like
I'd never seen before a footage that was
not used in the movie and I saw
something really interesting in a behind
the scenes that they did was with
Spielberg on set while they were making
the movie and he talked about how he
cast people that could be very big so
that he could scale them back in editing
and in some of the cutscenes that they
showed on the blu-ray that was evident I
was like wow this doesn't feel like jaws
oh of course not that's why they cut it
out and stuff but even the behind the
scenes thing was just packed with
information if you're a jaws lover pick
up the 45th anniversary limited edition
if you're a jaws lover pick up designing
jaws Joe Alves book Joe thank you for
dreaming up a world in which we all got
to escape man Hamady as we as you know
means friendship and that's that
friendship has extended for forty-five
years man thank you
as we just finally met now but thank you
for everything that you've given me
since I was five years old because it
worked out for me I wound up in the
movies because of this movie it's been a
real pleasure to talk to you Kruger oh
you great stuff you're a legend Sir
thank you for everything you've done
take care that is SModcast ladies and
gentlemen I'm Kevin Smith Joe l have a
week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this has been a production of Smaug Co
internet radio sir
only at SModcast calm